this mission to northeast asia ended
as it had begun with the u.s directly
accusing
china of aggressive behavior in the
region but the u.s and south korea
also confirmed beijing's importance in
the denuclearization of north korea
but china has a real interest in helping
to deal with this it also has an
obligation
under the u.n security council
resolutions the u.s had tried to open a
dialogue with north korea
ahead of this trip but without success
north korea has officially confirmed it
had received those requests
but didn't respond its first vice
foreign minister chai son he
saying there can be no dialogue until
the u.s
stops what she called its hostile
behavior
making it clear pyongyang is waiting to
see
what the new policy of the biden
administration towards it
will look like this mission is intended
to help formulate that strategy
it's also aimed at restoring and
repairing relations between the us
and its traditional allies in northeast
asia
as the u.s has repeatedly said the
trilateral security cooperation between
seoul tokyo and washington is crucial
considering the international situation
and newly emerging security threats
relations often severely strained during
the previous administration of donald
trump
that advantage for the united states has
been greatly
uh ruined during the four years of trump
administration
so it is important for the biden
administration to
restore the strategic asset that united
states has
and china does not one of the last acts
on this visit
a cost-sharing agreement for the basing
of u.s troops in south korea
disputed for years by the trump
administration
its final signing seen here as evidence
of an alliance restored rob mcbride al
jazeera seoul